Gary so I have been a chef an event
manager for more than two decades and
the philosophy has been you're only as
good as your last event you're only as
good as your last meal you have been the
seminal figure in deconstructing that so
thank you now in the social media realm
can you speak to that of not letting the
perfect to be your enemy and just I I
think the imperfect so first of all I
think intent Trump's all and I think the
second you really understand what I just
said you become far more you know lucid
in your communication I'm never scared
to doing the wrong thing tweeting the
wrong thing promoting too much because
I'll apologize if I really feel like I
was wrong
I actually consulted one of my clients
to do something wrong on purpose so we
could say we're sorry because I think
the sorry is more valuable than the
status quo and it's crazy so the reason
I'm not crippled by perfection or has to
be perfect or anything of that nature as
a matter of fact the one thing I've been
most scared about with this book coming
out is people critiquing what I'm
putting out content wise against your
own against my own speak because what
I'm doing is I'm still testing so I'm
still putting out links that
auto-populate the pictures on facebook
because I'm always testing and I'm like
oh man this is gonna be tough to explain
because somebody's gonna jump into me
like Gary Vee you just gonna wrote a
book about you got to make a picture why
are you doing this and so you know I've
never crippled by cuz intent matters
because when I reply to that person say
listen I'm still testing baseline
because Facebook's always changing
they're like oh there's like more value
for me to continue the smarts than me
being crippled by doing the wrong thing
so I think it's quite simple I think
that if you're willing to respect your
your your haters or the people that
don't agree or the people that are upset
with your last meal as long as you're
willing to respect them and have true
dialog you can't lose